hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to in 1969
Sesame Street was born an educational
show that actually made learning numbers
letters and words somewhat entertaining
it was put together by puppeteer legends
Frank Oz Jim Henson and a few others for
a while it was everywhere and you can
believe it this show is actually still
on TV running almost 40 years non-stop
surely there must be some kind of movie
we can exploit out of this luckily there
is in 1985 Warner Brothers released
their big-screen motion picture
groundbreaking epic follow that bird
good lord this is going to be painful
the show itself never made any sense so
what makes people think that a movie
about it is gonna make any sense I
haven't seen this movie in years I just
remember that was weird
and childish I mean okay it's a
children's movie but that's beside the
point
it's time I look over this crazy
nonsensical garbage and give it the
beating that it deserves so let's dive
right in at the beginning ladies and
gentlemen would you please rise for the
Grouch anthem with a grouch anthem you
stay sitting down oh my god Oscar I
haven't seen him in years
he's like the first puppet I ever saw my
entire life he's like totally
responsible for the grumpy person now
they had today I mean I just looked up
to him I just loved him and I'm sure
this movie still gonna blow this bite
him all right so it starts out with an
organization called the feathered
friends which apparently relocates
orphan birds with proper families it
turns out that Big Bird is on that list
do look at this information with someone
stalking him and one representativeness
Finch goes to his aid
so this logically brings us to Sesame
Street where we of course come across oh
my god he's just as big as I remember
him some things never change when you're
a jack
it's a man in a costume a big lovable
heartwarming costume so he's told that
there's a family called the Dodos were
willing to take him in and look after
him so Big Bird always looking for our
family agrees and decides to say goodbye
to all his friends Oh
he's like a big hairy Dumbo but with
depression Oh Snuffy I guess this is
goodbye
Oh bird oh no big bird only dolly mr.
snuffleupagus hey did you go what the
hell's wrong with me understands a
critic not a push if I'd emotional cries
over every Sesame Street related motion
picture epic where every person puppet
educational crappy animated animal tugs
at your heartstrings critic okay so Big
Bird goes to live with the Dodos but
finds he's not really fitting in mostly
because the Dodos are certifiably insane
it's pretty bad when a group of
characters seems so crazy that even a
Sesame Street movie can't pull them off
as normal
great Tyler get the door marine la I'm
go on you get your letter doorman
regular go on and get it no don't be
stubborn
this is worse than I thought
wanting to keep his mental health
bickered runs away and tries to get back
home but miss Finch is determined to get
him back before he reaches his
destination
so the Sesame Street gang goes looking
for the gang consisting of Oscar and Oh
Grover the count Cookie Monster and Oh
as you notice uh Bert and Ernie are
sharing the exact same plane that's
because they also share the exact same
bet see it's because I can't do it I got
made fun of Sesame Street it's the first
show I ever saw I'm sorry about the gay
joke Burton Ernie
whatever your sexual preference is it's
none of my business I'm sorry big bird
I'm sorry Grover I'm sorry everybody I
love you all you're also beautiful and
innocent to me you are child ha ha ha I
can't do it oh I'm done get someone else
to review them for me I can't do it
hey you you want 20 bucks go view this
movie hurry
oh I am here to review was never this
movie again follow that bird oh my god
this is the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life this is bird who runs
away from home we need to run away from
his home again do get back to the first
home that he went away from in the first
place and that's this lady who looks
like one of my acid fantasies and she is
trying to bring him back home to the
home that he ran away from the second
time now I know that is Mika who
lattices so anyway there's these two
guys and they're like too good to be
bird and they're like let's paint in
blue for some reason and parade him
around like an animal which he is an
animal so it just that's legal meanwhile
Bert and Ernie are flying Super Grover
is flying and Oscar is flying except on
the ground and Cookie Monster ate his
car because he thought it was a cookie
are you got my car with a cookie ones
but it wasn't a cookie or a car it was
man so they find me bird in a person
like hooray
but then they're like oh crap so they
have a big car chase scene
like Japanese like though and then I
jump in he's like no then I jump in he's
like okay so the bad guys are taken away
by Officer John Candy and Big Bird is
returned back to Sesame Street
but Miss Fitch is like I have to take
you back home and paper it is like -
what is your deal everybody's like this
is is oh go back to Russia so the move
of the story is home is not about where
you belong where you need to be it's all
about where you would live I have even a
but through their blue doggies I'll
insist you're a bum saying I remember
some you don't say you can't change I
cannot have a guy olya come on change
well can you at least tell me how to get
to Sesame Street
nobody seems to know